pandemic has hurt so many companies but  social distancing  and remote work has brightened business  for the candle industry maybe something  you didn't think about  etsy says business for candles has  nearly tripled in the past three months  when compared to 2019  and that is a big boost for people who  are laid off or need to work from home  there was a pair these two they were  actually furloughed from disney world  they now create candles inspired by  their favorite musicals  as far as manufacturing goes i know most  of us  are running 24 7. we are struggling to  keep up with demand  so she is a vice president at the  national candle association  and says the candle industry is worth  three and a half billion dollars in the  u.s  with millennials being the biggest  consumers and sherry and i have also  supported that effort